talk to me about the problem with nice
guys essentially what nice guys do is
what they suffer with is not that
they're too nice or anything it's just
that they have incredibly weak
boundaries when it comes to women what
they do is they blame the fact that
they're so nice as to why they can't get
women but it's not about being nice it's
about a lack of masculinity one of the
best ways to establish masculinity is
placing boundaries when you don't like a
behavior you don't roll over and allow
it to continue and then give her more in
order for you to get her you set a
boundary and you have a willingness to
walk away nice guys what happens is they
don't like to exert their boundaries and
they don't have a willingness to walk
away so what ends up happening is their
nice nature becomes a reason for
resentment because women don't like it
they actually feel angry when you're too
nice to them because then they don't
feel protected they feel like you're
weak because she'll feel like she has to
raise you and she'll lose respect for
you what we truly want is we can trust
makes good decisions but the one that
doesn't trust his own decision- making
and we have to do it and he comes across
as being nice essentially he's seen as
weak